meta's vast Menlo Park Campus is about
to get a bit quieter the tech giant
which owns Instagram and WhatsApp and
used to be called Facebook is
unfriending 11 000 of its 87 000 strong
Workforce falling ad revenues and lower
than expected growth have taken the
Shine off Silicon Valley stocks but meta
has suffered particularly for failing to
excite investors with its virtual
reality vision of the metaverse
pioneered some of the early VR tools for
big Tech you know they were called
Facebook and they decided they needed to
Rebrand the entire company around this
concept of the metaverse without
necessarily making sure that everybody
was was on board with what that meant
and they didn't have a really crisp idea
of what it was and then when when they
started showing what they meant by it a
lot of people were like yeah that's not
really what I wanted
so I think that's what we're dealing
with now
it's not that Wall Street doubts virtual
or augmented reality is the future more
just how much time and money meta is
using to get there meta has been
spending a staggering amount of money
creating the metaverse up to 15 billion
dollars in research and development in
the last year alone that's the same as
the r d budget for the entire UK
in fact investors have found hard to
swallow given smaller companies in a
garage rather than a campus are doing
creative things with the same Tech
so tell me what I'm looking at tell me
where I am well you're in the Soma
neighborhood of San Francisco Avatar is
a startup using meta's VR technology but
their own app which allows it to
transport remote customers to real
places rather than put them in expensive
virtual ones I mean it's literally like
you and I are taking a stroll down the
street yet I'm sitting in your office
and you are taking me on a stroll down
the street being creative with VR
technology is arguably easier when
you're smaller than meta when you're
betting a multi-billion dollar public
company on the proposition that this
becomes you know an industry Within
how many years three years five years
that's a risky bet but um a bold one you
got to give them credit for that is that
a bet that they've lost oh I don't think
so definitely not it's it's much too
early to say that the BET's been lost
the rest of big Tech is suffering too
Apple Google Amazon and Microsoft
together with meta have seen 3.7
trillion dollars wiped off their
combined value in the last year
it's far from the death of big Tech but
a reality check that's anything but
virtual Tom Clark Sky News San Francisco